THEIR VOTE.
SEE YOU.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A REMARKABLE DAY.
BRETT KAVANAUGH JUST STEPPED
AWAY FROM THE MICROPHONE IN
THE SENATE HEARING ROOM.
HE SPENT THREE AND A HALF
HOURS THERE.
IT WAS A REMARKABLE MOMENT.
STUNNING IN MANY WAYS LIKE
WITHOUT PRECEDENT AND
LIFETIMES OF MANY WHO WATCHED
IT.
UNTIL THIS AFTERNOON,
KAVANAUGH HAD STRUCK MANY WHO
WATCHED HIM AS BOOKISH AND
ACADEMIC.
THE CLASSIC TEMPER AMOUNT OF A
FEDERAL JUDGE.
BUT HE EMERGED TRANSFORMED.
A MAN ON FIRE, FIGHTING WITH
EVERYTHING TO SAVE HIS FAMILY,
HIMSELF AND THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
KAVANAUGH BEGAN THE TESTIMONY
WITH AN UNEQUIVOCAL DENIAL OF
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST HIM.
I DID NOT SEXUALLY ASSAULT
CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD OR ANYONE
ELSE AT ANY TIME.
HIS VOICE RISING.
"THE ALLEGATIONS ARE FALSE."
BUT THEN HE BROADENED THE
RESPONSE AND AIMED IT AT
SENATE DEMOCRATS BEFORE HIM.
>> THIS CONFIRMATION PROCESS
HAS BECOME A NATIONAL
DISGRACE.
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES THE
SENATE AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS.
BUT YOU HAVE REPLACED A VICE
AND CONCEPT WITH SEARCH AND
DESTROY.
SINCE MY NOMINATION IN JULY,
THERE HAS BEEN A FRENZY ON THE
LEFT TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING, ANYTHING, TO BLOCK
MY CONFIRMATION.
SHORTLY AFTER I WAS NOMINATED,
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATE LEADER
SAID HE WOULD, "OPPOSE ME WITH
EVERYTHING HE'S GOT.
" A DEMOCRATIC SENATOR ON THIS
COMMITTEE PUBLICLY REFERRED TO
ME AS "EVIL."
EVIL.
THINK ABOUT THAT WORD.
AND SAID THOSE WHO SUPPORTED
ME WERE "COMPLICIT IN EVIL."
ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC SENATOR ON
THIS COMMITTEE SAID, "JUDGE
KAVANAUGH IS YOUR WORST
NIGHTMARE."
A FORMER HEAD OF THE NATIONAL
COMMITTEE SAID, "JUDGE
KAVANAUGH WILL THREATEN THE
LIVES OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
FOR DECADES TO COME."
I UNDERSTAND THE PASSIONS OF
THE MOMENT.
BUT I WOULD SAY TO THOSE
SENATORS, YOUR WORDS HAVE
MEANING.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS LISTEN
CAREFULLY TO YOU.
GIVEN COMMENTS LIKE THOSE, IS
IT ANY SURPRISE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING.
TO MAKE ANY PHYSICAL THREAT
AGAINST MY FAMILY.
TO SEND ANY VIOLENT E-MAIL TO
MY WIFE.
TO MAKE ANY KIND OF ALLEGATION
AGAINST ME AND AGAINST MY
FRIENDS TO BLOW ME UP AND TAKE
ME DOWN.
YOU SOWED THE WIND.
FOR DECADES TO COME, I FEAR
THAT THE WHOLE COUNTRY WILL
REAP THE WHIRL WINDS.
>> Tucker: NO SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE HAS SPOKEN IN MEMORY.
NOT EVEN CLARENCE THOMAS.
BUT NONE HAS BEEN MORE ACCUSED
MORE RECKLESSLY OR WITH LESS
EVIDENCE THAN BRETT KAVANAUGH
HAS.
AND HE DID NOTHING TO HIDE HIS
RAGE.
>> THIS WHOLE TWO-WEEK EFFORT
HAS BEEN A CALCULATED AND AN
ORCHESTRATED POLITICAL HIT.
FUELED WITH APPARENT PENT-UP
ANGER ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE 2016 ELECTION.
FEAR THAT HAS BEEN UNFAIRLY
STOKED ABOUT MY JUDICIAL
RECORD.
REVENGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CLINTONS.
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
MONEY FROM OUTSIDE LEFT WING
OPPOSITION GROUPS.
THIS IS A CIRCUS.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL EXTEND
LONG PAST MY NOMINATION.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE WITH
US FOR DECADES.
THIS GROTESQUE AND COORDINATED
CHARACTER ASSASSINATION WILL
DISSUADE COMPETENT, GOOD
PEOPLE OF ALL POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS FROM SERVING OUR
COUNTRY.
AS WE ALL KNOW IN THE UNITED
STATES POLITICAL SYSTEM OF THE
EARLY 2000s, WHAT GOES
AROUND COMES AROUND.
I AM AN OPTIMISTIC GUY.
I ALWAYS TRY TO BE ON THE
SUNRISE SIDE OF THE MOUNTAIN.
TO BE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE DAY
THAT IS COMING.
BUT TODAY, I HAVE TO SAY THAT
I FEAR FOR THE FUTURE.
>> Tucker: THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING HE CATEGORICALLY
DENIES NO CLAIMS TOWARD HIM
BUT SHOWS NO ANIMUS PERSONALLY
TOWARD CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD.
HE EXPLAINED HOW HIS FAMILY
HAD PRAYED FOR HER IN ONE OF
THE MOST RIVETTING MOMENTS OF
THE DAY.
>> I'M NOT QUESTIONING THAT
DR. FORD MAY HAVE BEEN SEXUAL
ASSAULTED BY SOME PERSON IN
SOME PLACE, AT SOME TIME.
BUT I HAVE NEVER DONE THIS.
TO HER, OR TO ANYONE.
THAT IS NOT WHO I AM.
IT IS NOT WHO I WAS.
I AM INNOCENT OF THIS CHARGE.
I INTEND NO ILL-WILL TO
DR. FORD AND HER FAMILY.
THE OTHER NIGHT, ASHLEY AND MY
DAUGHTER LIZA SAID THEIR
PRAYERS AND LIZA ALL OF 10
YEARS OLD SAID TO ASHLEY, "WE
SHOULD PRAY FOR THE WOMAN."
A LOT OF WISDOM FROM A 10
-YEAR-OLD.
WE MEAN NO ILL WILL.
>> Tucker: BEHIND HIM AS HE
SPOKE, BRETT KAVANAUGH'S
MOTHER WEPT WITH EMOTION.
HE CONCLUDED HIS REMARKS TODAY
AS HE BEGUN THEM, DEFIANTLY.
>> I ARE NOT BE INTIMIDATED
INTO WITHDRAWING FROM THIS
PROCESS.
YOU HAVE TRY HARD.
YOU HAVE GIVEN IT YOUR ALL.
NO ONE CAN QUESTION YOUR
EFFORT.
BUT YOUR COORDINATED AND WELL
FUNDED EFFORT TO DESTROY MY
GOOD NAME AND DESTROY MY
FAMILY WILL NOT DRIVE ME OUT.
THE VILE THREATS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST MY FAMILY WILL NOT
DRIVE ME OUT.
YOU MAY DEFEAT ME IN THE FINAL
VOTE, BUT YOU WILL NEVER GET
ME TO QUIT.
NEVER.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS IN THE
ROOM SEEMED STUNNED BY
KAVANAUGH'S REMARKS AND FOR A
MOMENT THEY SEEMED THROWN BACK
ON THEIR HEELS.
BUT NOT FOR LONG.
RANKING MEMBER DIANNE
FEINSTEIN BEGAN THE
QUESTIONING FOR DEMOCRATS.
SHE SEEMED TO SUGGEST THAT
KAVANAUGH WAS SECRETLY A
SEXUAL PREDATOR.
READING FROM A SCRIPT SHE
REFERRED TO A WOMAN CALLED
JULIE SWETNICK, COLLEGE
STUDENT IN SUBURBAN WASHINGTON
WHEN BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
YESTERDAY AS WE TOLD YOU,
SWETNICK CLAIMED THAT SHE
WITNESSED AT LEAST TEN PUBLIC
GANG RAPES IN WHICH BRETT
KAVANAUGH WAS SUPPOSEDLY
PRESENT AND PARTICIPATING.
REMARKABLE CHARGE.
FEINSTEIN NEVER MENTIONED THAT
PART OF SWETNICK'S CLAIM.
WHY IS THAT?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT CLASHES WITH COMMON SENSE
AND IT'S LUNATIC.
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT.
FEINSTEIN LEFT THAT PART OUT
IN ORDER TO SMEAR KAVANAUGH IN
FRONT OF THE WORLD AND OMITTED
HIGHLY RELEVANT INFORMATION
ABOUT HIS ACCUSER.
INDEED THE ENTIRE ACCUSATION.
IT WAS REPREHENSIBLY DISHONEST
BEHAVIOR, ESPECIALLY FOR A
U.S. SENATOR.
KAVANAUGH ALL BUT SAID SO.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT GETTING
THE EVIDENCE AND HAVING THE
EVIDENCE LOOKED AT.
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, WE HEAR FROM THE
WITNESSES.
BUT THE F.B.I. ISN'T
INTERVIEWING THEM AND ISN'T
GIVING US ANY FACTS.
SO ALL WE HAVE.
>> YOU'RE INTERVIEWING ME.
YOU'RE INTERVIEWING ME.
YOU'RE DOING IT, SENATOR.
I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT BUT YOU
ARE DOING IT.
THERE IS NO CONCLUSIONS
REACHED.
>> WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IF I
UNDERSTAND IT, IS THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS BY DR. FORD,
MS. RAMIREZ, AND MS. SWETNICK
ARE WRONG.
>> THAT IS EMPHATICALLY WHAT
I'M SAYING.
EMPHATICALLY.
THE SWETNICK THING IS A JOKE.
THAT IS A FARCE.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY MORE
ABOUT IT?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: IT WAS A SURREAL
MOMENT.
THE DAY WAS FILLED WITH THOSE.
AT TIMES THE HYPOCRISY LEVEL
GOT SO HIGH YOU WONDERED HOW
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM COULD
BREATHE.
THERE WAS THE ONLY SENATOR
FROM NEW JERSEY A MAN WHO ONCE
ADMITTED MOLESTING A GIRL IN
HIGH SCHOOL SIT THERE ACCUSING
SOMEONE ELSE OF MOLESTING A
GIRL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> THERE ARE DOCK ELEMENTS
THAT ALLOW UNCONSCIONABLE
LEVEL OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT.
YOU ARE OPENING UP TO OPEN AIR
HURT AND PAIN THAT GOES ON
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU WERE SPEAKING TRUTH,
THIS COUNTRY NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND.
>> Tucker: IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO HEAR THAT THE
GIRL CORY BOOKER SAYS MOLESTED
SPEAK HER TRUTH.
WE EAGERLY AWAIT THAT
TESTIMONY, HOPEFULLY SOON.
BLOODLESS SENATOR FROM
CONNECTICUT WHO LIED ABOUT
SERVING IN VIETNAM TRIED TO
IMPUGN ANOTHER MAN'S
INTEGRITY.
>> FALSE IN ONE THING, FALSE
IN EVERYTHING.
MEANING IN JURY INSTRUCTIONS
THAT SOME OF US AS PROSECUTORS
HEARD MANY TIMES, IS TOLD A
JURY THAT THEY CAN DISBELIEVE
A WITNESS IF THEY FIND HIM TO
BE FALSE IN ONE THING.
SO THE CORE OF WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY REALLY IS CREDIBILITY.
>> THE CORE OF WHY WE ARE HERE
IS THE ALLEGATION OF THE FOUR
WITNESSES PRESENT SAID IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: FALSE IN ONE
THING, FALSE IN MANY THINGS.
IF YOU ARE SENATOR BLUMENTHAL
CAN YOU IMAGINE SAYING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
WHAT KIND OF LOOK OF
SELF-AWARENESS WOULD IT TAKE
TO SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
REMARKABLE.
UNDERNEATH ALL OF THIS,
THOUGH, HUNG THE MOST OBVIOUS
QUESTION OF THE DAY WHICH
NOBODY ASKED OUT LOUD.
WHO DID THIS TO CHRSTINE
BLASEY FORD?
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY HELD THE
HEARINGS FOR HER.
IT WAS DEMOCRATS WHO LEAKED
HER NAME TO PRESS AGAINST HER
WISHES AND DRAGGED HER IN THE
MAELSTROM.
WHO DID IS THAT?
LIKELY SOMEONE IN DIANNE
FEINSTEIN'S OFFICE.
FEINSTEIN CLAIMS SHE WAS
INVOLVED.
SHE WOULD LIKE THE PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE ON THAT.
OKAY.
SO WHO WAS IT?
IF YOU CARE ABOUT CHRSTINE
BLASEY FORD AND ABOUT ALL
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT, YOU
WOULD BE ANXIOUS TO KNOW.
MAYBE WE COULD HAVE A NEW
INVESTIGATION IN THAT.
REPUBLICANS COULD START ONE
IMMEDIATELY.
LIKE TOMORROW.
WOULD DEMOCRATS PARTICIPATE IN
AN INVESTIGATION TO FIND OUT
WHO LEAKED FORD'S NAME NO THE
PRESS?
PROBABLY NOT.
THEY SEEM STRIKINGLY
UNINTERESTED IN TALKING ABOUT
CHRISTINE FORD TODAY.
THEY RARELY ASKED ABOUT HER
WHEN JUDGE KAVANAUGH ON THE
SET.
INSTEAD THEY PEPPERED HIM
ABOUT THE GEORGETOWN PREP
YEARBOOK AND HOW MUCH BEER HE
DRANK IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE.
THIS IS ONE OF HIS RESPONSES
TO THE LINE OF QUESTIONING.
>> I NEVER SEXUAL ASSAULTED
ANYONE.
THERE IS A BRIGHT LINE BETWEEN
DRINKING BEER WHICH I GLADLY
DO, AND WHICH I FULLY EMBRACE,
AND SEXUAL ASSAULTING SOMEONE
WHICH IS A VIOLENT CRIME.
IF EVERY AMERICAN WHO DRINKS
BEER OR EVERY AMERICAN WHO
DRANK BEER IN HIGH SCHOOL IS
SUDDENLY RESUMED GUILTY OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT, IT WILL BE AN
UGLY NEW PLACE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I NEVER COMMITTED SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
>> Tucker: WHEN THEY WERE
DEMANDING ANSWERS ABOUT THE
HIGH SCHOOL YEARBOOK DEMOCRATS
STALLED FOR TIME.
THEY DID THAT TO TRY TO GET
ANOTHER F.B.I. INVESTIGATION
INTO KAVANAUGH.
>> WHY AREN'T YOU ALSO ASKING
THE F.B.I. TO INVESTIGATE THE
CLAIMS?
>> JUDGE KAVANAUGH, WILL YOU
SUPPORT AN F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION RIGHT NOW?
>> YOU COULD ACTUALLY JUST GET
THIS OPEN SO WE CAN TALK TO
THESE WITNESSES.
AND THE F.B.I. CAN DO IT
INSTEAD OF US.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO ASK THE
WHITE HOUSE TO AUTHORIZE THE
F.B.I. TO INVESTIGATE CLAIMS
MADE AGAINST YOU?
>> Tucker: AN F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION SOUNDS
REASONABLE.
I WOULD BE THE SEVENTH F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION THAT HAS LOOKED
DEEPLY INTO BRETT KAVANAUGH'S
PERSONAL CONDUCT.
HE WAS ONCE STAFF SECRETARY TO
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND HAD THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SECURITY CLEARANCE THIS
COUNTRY GIVES.
ONE THAT GAVE HIM ACCESS TO
THE AMERICA NUCLEAR CODES.
HE GOT THAT CLEARANCE BECAUSE
THE F.B.I. SPOKE AT LENGTH TO
A CROSS SECTION OF EVERYONE HE
HAD EVERY MET GOING BACK TO
HIGH SCHOOL OR EARLIER AND
THERE WERE NO HINT OF SEXUAL
ASSAULTS.
NONE.
THERE IS NOTHING LEFT TO
INVESTIGATE HERE.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
THIS IS A POLITICAL TACTIC AND
IT'S DISINGENUOUS.
WHY ARE THEY DOING IT?
SIMPLE.
DEMOCRATS KNOW IF THE VOTE ON
BRETT KAVANAUGH IS HELD SOON
HE WILL BE CONFIRMED.
IF IT'S DELAYED BY POINTLESS
F.B.I. INVESTIGATIONS DEMANDED
BY DEMAGOGUES IN BAD FAITH HE
WILL NOT BE CONFIRMED BECAUSE
THE ACCUSATIONS WILL NEVER
END.
THE INCENTIVE TO MADE THEM IS
TOO STRONG.
YOU WILL SEE ANONYMOUS CLAIMS
HE LED GANG RAPES ON SAILBOATS
IN RHODE ISLAND OR WHEREVER.
AND THE STANDARD OF JUSTICE
WILL DEGRADE.
WITH THE HELP OF THE
CONFERENCE.
THE DEMOCRATS RETAIN POWER AND
THAT IS THE POINT.
THE ONLY POINT OF ALL OF THIS.
BUT FOR NOW UNTIL AND IF THAT
HAPPENS NO REPUBLICAN SENATOR
WHO WATCHED KAVANAUGH TESTIFY
TODAY ARE LIKED TO VOTE
AGAINST HIM.
THOSE WHO DID WOULD BE
PUNISHED BY VOTERS.
MANY VOTERS AT HOME WEPT AS
THEY WATCHED KAVANAUGH
TESTIFY.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE BEEN
ACCUSED WRONGLY KNOW WELL THE
EMOTION ON HIS FACE.
PROVE YOU DIDN'T DO IT OR
EVERYTHING YOU HAVE BE TAKEN
AWAY FROM YOU.
HE CAME AS CLOSE AS HE COULD
TO CLEAR HIS NAME.
HE DIDN'T GET HELP FROM THE
REPUBLICANS OTHER THAN LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
THE NEXT TIME YOU ARE FALSELY
ACCUSED OF A CRIME DON'T ASK
THEM FOR A BACKUP.
KAVANAUGH DID IT HIMSELF.
HE HAD NO CHOICE.